[Musique]
je vais vous raconter une histoire une
histoire que vous croyez sûrement
connaître mais en fait non
là devant c'est quoi ça
papa
cette chose parle c'est rien qu'un pas
en train de boire c'est pas vrai je suis
un vrai petit garçon
parfois les gens ont un peu peur des
choses qui ne connaissent pas j'ai du
mal à comprendre
nous l'avons trouvé c'est notre étoile
[Musique]
tout le monde va t'aduler et scander ton
nom Pinocchio et
occhio alors ils viennent petites choses
que je voudrais te donner c'est un
manuel il appartenait un petit garçon
très cher à mon cœur le fils que tu as
perdu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dis-lui que je l'aime très fort
[Musique]
et que je ne serai plus jamais un
fardeau
il y a quelqu'un
[Musique]
le garçon de bois à qui l'on a prêté une
âme tu as beau avoir la vie éternelle ce
que tu aimes ne l'ont pas on ne sait pas
le temps qu'il nous reste avec quelqu'un
jusqu'à son départ
son cousin comme vous êtes
sur le chemin de la sagesse
ne faites pas ça ne lui faites pas de
mal tu n'as peut-être pas de ficelle
mais tu restes sous mon contrôle
[Musique]
je vous en prie rendez le moi
la vie est un cadeau tout à fait
merveilleux